a tragic morning in the Indian city of
Luciano
several people collapsed outside a milk
store others were found unconscious in
their homes nearby in the morning we
found that some people had collapsed and
it looked like a case of contamination
of some gas that had leaked
emergency service teams say people
complained about headaches and a bad
smell
some had difficulties breathing
authorities issued evacuation orders and
sealed off the area while they
determined the source of the gas
after the team takes samples and
Compares them to the blood test results
then we will be able to tell you the
exact cause and which kind of gas
in 1984 India had one of the world's
worst industrial disasters a gas leak at
a pesticide Factory in Bhopal killed
thousands of people
similar incidents occurred in 2017 and
2020.
as families mourn their loved ones their
calling on authorities to improve safety
standards in industrial areas